welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the upcoming mcu fantastic four
debut is starting to come more and more
in focus with new speculative reports
that marvel's first family could come as
soon as ant-man 3
and mystery details that we still have
no explanation for after hours
soon jim and movie pam will explain now
the evidence for the fantastic four
throughout the mcu is scattered like
buckshot
some of it wedged in past videos we've
made on this channel over the past year
so i'm gonna do some ballistics
forensics and yarn
back all of these clues into this master
theory for the fantastic four
doctor doom and a revised mcu timeline
spoiler warning in case any part of this
ends up being right because i have a
feeling some james gunn brand big
chunks of it will be accurate let's
rewind the clock one
year kevin feige confirmed at comic-con
last year that despite the fantastic
four not being announced for phase four
the title remains in development we
didn't even have time
to talk about the fantastic four yes you
did you totally
had time take his hat now this tease
came hot on the heels of the biggest
in-universe hint toward the fantastic
four yet
the final moments of spider-man far from
home in which peter parker glided
through the renovated avengers tower
atrium
probably past reed richards ben grimms
to storm i mean we wouldn't be able to
see her
and down to this street with a
mysterious sign reading we can't wait to
show you what comes next
one two three fantastic and many of us
immediately speculated that the new
occupants of avengers tower
the ones who renovated it are the
fantastic four and the tower is now
the baxter building but consider the
possibility that the fantastic four
are not the new tenants of that
structure but the original occupants
reclaiming it from a history that
reaches back long before anthony stark
signed the lease
now the new reports suggest that the
fantastic four could be debuting in
ant-man 3.
a movie that will answer some of our
unanswered questions about the quantum
realm like that
city that's visible in the background
which i increasingly believe is the
residence of
doctor doom mostly because one of doom's
oldest battles with a fantastic four
ended with doom seemingly shrinking out
of existence
and then revealed years later to have
become the ruler of a subatomic hidden
kingdom our most recent episode of rogue
theory tied this to the mystery of janet
van dyne's never
explained survival the possibility that
victor von doom could be
puppeting janet controlling her
telepathically the same way she
controlled scott lang telepathically
so that she could escape the quantum
realm and then return with pymtek
to free doom a theory that tommy coined
a villain is turned by janet van dyne or
should i say
janet von doom keep the monogram
you do not have to change the initials
the towels remain
the bathrobe remains the bowling ball
remains because j
v d is still in business now peyton reed
is returning to direct ant-man 3
and he reveals how long ago he pitched
to fox to direct a fantastic four movie
set
in the 1960s as many people remember
their retro
campy classic run in the comics but that
period in the mcu is very interesting
experimental gap period that we know
very
little about aside from some interesting
traces we know back in the 40s figures
like howard stark peggy carter working
for the first name strategic scientific
reserve later reorganized this shield
operated out of secret hidden labs all
over the new york city area
and one of howard stark's innovations
that he showed at the 1943 stark expo
was
phineas horton's synthetic man an easter
egg in captain america the first avenger
pointing to the early marvel comics the
original
human torch ooh later when that name
went to johnny's storm was part of the
fantastic four
now we also know that hank pym later
joined howard stark as a shield
scientist and operative in the 60s
we saw him in end game at camp lee high
in 1970
when cap lied to him to get him out of
the lab this is captain stevens from
shipping we have a package for you bring
it up
well that's the thing sir we can't sir
the box is glowing and
to be honest some of our male guys
aren't feeling that great they didn't
open it did they
uh yeah they did you better get down
here
excuse me out of the way
hank sure is freaked the [ __ ] out it's
almost like
something like this has happened before
a
previous glow that affected some of
hank's colleagues
in the years before this in the 60s
yes i believe that there was another
group of operatives during this period
that we're about to learn about and that
one of the strategic scientific reserves
hidden bases
in the new york area was in midtown
right near grand central
the baxter building i mean the met like
building that it was based on was built
in 1959 why don't we clock it around
there
yes in the 60s my friends while the rest
of the marvel world was sleeping and ice
or not born yet the fantastic war were
in new york experimenting with their
buddy hank pym
and 60's era howard stark who i just
assume is roger sterling which might be
why they cast him
exactly the 60s retro fantastic four
period piece that peyton reed envisioned
i assume with auction power's dance and
interlude but then the party ends
tragedy strikes
in the lab a mysterious glow irradiates
reed richards sue storm johnny storm ben
graham
and victor von doom these five fade from
existence
and this is the moment hank pym
discovers what caused this tech that he
later renamed
pym particles i know this is a lot to
process so let's shift gears to
something
smaller more digestible more compact
like the most discreet front pocket
while at the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode the ridge helps you carry what
you need every day from their flagship
ridge wallet
through their portable charging commuter
backpack they want to make the most out
of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
carbon fiber it has a clean stylish look
it's chainsaw proof so when all those
tiki hating jerks come
at you with chainsaws their attacks will
be not very effective this is their
aluminum tiki wallet
they do have other colors like matte
cobalt blue or forged carbon fiber
all of them they're light they're strong
they're ready to party
but only with the minimal amount of cash
that you brought with you because you
don't need to bring everything they make
it easy to buy with free shipping and
free returns and a lifetime guarantee
it's got thirty thousand five star
reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries get 10
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
okay so obviously we know hank's five
friends would have disappeared they just
went down into the quantum realm
and yes the quantum realm is the mcu's
microverse but ant-man and the wasp also
kind of gave it properties of the
negative zone the alternate dimension
where the fantastic war and doom get
their powers
just like the weird supernatural
abilities janet got from there
there's so much we didn't know about
this place henry
world upon worlds entire civilizations
far more than we ever theorized but that
energy
from your hands how did you do that
i'm not the same woman i was 30 years
ago henry
this place it changes you
i mean adaptation is part of it but some
of it is
evolution now would this mean the
fantastic four that we see in the mcu
are like
super old if or when they arrive at
ant-man 3 well no
the reason for this lies in the
confusion many of you continue to have
about why janet van dyne
aged 30 years in the quantum realm while
scott lang aged only five hours
despite being there for five years in
our time time vortexes are
separate things within the quantum realm
scott went into a time vortex janet did
not she just stayed in the broader tier
of the quantum realm in which time
passes normally that is why janet
warns scott don't get sucked into a time
vortex we won't be able to save you
so janet obviously didn't herself go
into one of these time vortexes during
her time in the quantum realm yet
she still knew about him enough to
caution others
how did she know 20 years before janet
arrived in the quantum realm in the late
80s
there were four refugees to this realm
who decided to venture even deeper
into a time vortex and poof god
a ghost story told you janet by that
quartet's leftover companion
victor von doom he stayed behind
he gained powers he built a civilization
and now
he has the partner of the man who exiled
him there
he can use her to escape and seek his
revenge
now i explained in a past video how
modok and aim could tie into ant-man 3
as the
mysterious benefactor funding sunny
birch who's after pym tech maybe with
mcu merging modoc with the disembodied
zola ai and maybe zola modoc could be
doom's contact on the surface
working with telepathically controlled
janet von doom to use pymtak to
resurrect
dr doom from the quantum realm meanwhile
the fantastic four
reads sue johnny ben they spent a
shorter amount of time in the quantum
realm's energy field
but long enough to gain powers of
elasticity invisibility
rock flesh combustion but before they
aged too much they
wrote a time vortex to the future maybe
latching on to one of the avengers
returning from the time heist
or to thanos's forces when nebula
brought them from the past
popping up on the surface on mcu 2023
this foursome reclaims their midtown
base and rejoins their old buddy hank
pym
and his partner janet all while fully
unaware of the evil of their old
colleague ready to rise and come back to
haunt them
when victor and those who serve him make
their move in ant-man 3.
that my friends is how you get the still
young and beautiful gem and movie pam as
reed and sue
with an older creepier more powerful and
yet still beautiful kristoff waltz as
victor i hope
in a post in game phase 4 dimension
hopping revised manhattan skyline mcu
that was all in under 10 minutes
feigning you had plenty of time
join this nerdy theory discussion on our
official discord server by becoming a
patreon patreon.com
new rockstars follow me on instagram
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
for breakdowns of everything you love
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]